Dia 300 de la volta al món a peu.
M'encanten els camells, tu.
Em flipa.
Bueno, avui és un dia molt important a la Xina
i avui és un dia molt important per mi perquè és el dia 300.
25 de setembre de 2026
és el dia de la celebració de la festa de la mitja tardor, podríem dir.
És un festival, una festa de tot el país
i, com veieu, està tot decorat amb banderes xineses.
A part d'això, bueno, hi ha molt ambient al carrer, hi ha molts turistes.
Ara ja havia... Estaven fent aquí una espècie de show
a Uigur, aquí amb valls i vestint la gent i tal.
Bueno, avui hi ha diverses coses que farem.
Per començar anirem a sopar amb gent xinesa
que em portaran a un lloc, no ho sé.
Gairebé no parlen anglès, però crec que vindran del cai, que em podran traduir.
I després menjarem pastís
i anirem a veure algun dels events que fan aquesta nit.
Després us ho explico més.
So, where are we going?
No, my English is not good.
Restaurant?
Molt difícil.
Food? Eat?
Eat.
Chicken?
Ok, chicken, m'agrada.
Porto uns quants dies
anant amb gent molt vegetariana,
cosa que també està molt bé, però...
Home, carnaca també ve de gust.
Bueno, clarament aquest és un lloc de pollastre
perquè està decorat amb aquests superpollastres,
però hem demanat uns aperitius.
No tinc ni idea del que és, jo em deixo guiar.
This, what is this?
Fish?
És que difícil traduir, eh?
Looks like fish.
No, it's not.
No és.
Diu que no sap el que és.
Ok.
Noodles?
Liang cao.
Liang feng.
And this?
Eggs?
Eggs for...
What animal?
Chicken?
Chicken.
Ah, però el que diuen està fet d'una determinada manera
perquè és molt raro, són negres.
Ous del centenari crec que es diuen.
Boníssim.
Bueno, i després ve el pollastre.
Tot està boníssim.
Com sempre,
i hi ha una quantitat, com sempre, de menjar molt bèstia.
La planta aquesta de pollastre...
Fa!
És enorme, eh?
Enorme.
Crec que en aquests vlogs que estic fent últimament
estic parlant molt de menjar.
I ja està, jo crec que de menjar ja està.
Anem a parlar més d'altres coses
perquè em sembla que només parlo de halà.
I ara, a veure, a veure, a veure.
Ja s'ha fet de nit, comença la festa.
Bueno, m'han dit que aquí a la terrassa...
Ui, mira, sí, hi ha gent ballant.
I hi ha una cosa molt tradicional del dia d'avui,
que és el...
Moon cake.
Anem a provar-lo, a veure.
A veure, això és el moon cake.
Anem a agafar, sembla que té sèsam, no?
A veure...
Ui, m'està alguna altra cosa.
A veure.
Anem a provar-lo.
Mmm, mmm.
No sé jo, eh?
Té una mica de sabor a truita, no?
Té un punt de sabor a truita, com si tingués molts ous.
Però no està malament,
té també molt de sabor a sèsam, que està bo.
Mmm, mmm, mmm.
Fins demà!
Qui era aquest senyor?
Quan va néixer i per què va ser important?
Doncs aquest senyor va néixer ara fa mil anys.
Mil anys, o sigui, fa moltíssim.
I va néixer al que seria
avui en dia Kirguistán, d'acord?
Us he dit diverses vegades
que els pobles
de Turquia, els turcs,
venen d'aquí, de l'àrea central.
I que hi ha països
túrquics, no? He anat dient, com per exemple
Uzbekistà és un
país túrquic, Tajikistà no ho és,
etcètera, i
els ruïgurs, els ruïgurs d'aquí són
un poble túrquic.
Però d'on ve això, no?
Doncs, bueno, és un poble
que de cop i volta van començar
a expandir-se.
A expandir-se de la zona de l'àrea central
i van arribar a Anatòlia,
és a dir, el que és la península més gran
d'aquesta, la península gran de Turquia, no?
Quan van arribar?
Doncs un any després
que aquest senyor publiqués
la seva obra més important,
que eren uns textos,
una espècie de poema filosòfic
que explicava com havia
de governar un rei. Aquest senyor va escriure
aquest poema tan llarg, tan important,
i li va presentar el governador de
Kejgar, d'aquest
regne d'aquí, no? Ostres, li va
agradar tant que el va anomenar al conseller,
al funcionari, no?
I això va ser el mil
setanta, aproximadament,
any mil setanta. Un any
després, els turcs
van arribar, van fer
la seva primera conquesta a
Anatòlia. Li van robar,
van conquistar una ciutat als bizantins
a l'extrem
est d'Anatòlia, el que avui
seria els confins
de l'estat turc, d'acord?
I, bueno, es van anar expandint
fins que van
arribar a Constantinople, i ja sabeu,
doncs, la caiguda de Constantinople, això va
ser quatre-cents anys més tard.
Boca broma. Llavors, bueno, són
clar, són tants anys,
tanta distància
que els pobles d'avui en dia,
turquics, no s'entenen
entre ells, no. Un turc
no es pot entendre amb un uigur.
Les llengües no
s'assemblen, no s'assemblen prou
com perquè s'entenguin, encara que tenen paraules
i són
molt semblants, tradicions, vull dir,
hem vist menjar aquí similar, etc.
L'he preguntat a la IA
i m'ha comentat que, per exemple,
el català i l'italià, o el català
i el castellà, són molt més semblants
entre si que el turc
i l'uigur.
Però a la vegada, el turc i l'uigur
s'assemblen més entre si
que el català i l'anglès,
d'acord? Perquè us feu una idea.
Home, Enric, és que el català i l'anglès
no s'assemblen gaire. Bueno, des del
nostre punt de vista no s'assemblen gaire,
però des del punt de vista d'un xinès,
per exemple, o d'algú que té
una llengua d'aquestes asiàtiques molt diferents,
sí que s'assemblen,
perquè hi ha moltes paraules que en realitat
són semblants de les llengües llatines
i de les llengües angleses, però bueno,
això és una altra
tema. Bueno,
joc maquíssim,
així blau,
amb aquestes raixoles,
però bueno, com tot aquí una mica, és una mica
relatiu. De fet,
aquesta tomba,
aquest mausoleu,
és un homenatge
que se li va fer a posteriori
de la mort d'aquest home. Abans de la
revolució cultural xinesa, als anys
60-70, això ja
estava construït, però a una altra banda,
a una altra banda de la ciutat, i
després de la revolució cultural, doncs ho van portar
aquí. D'acord, van moure
l'edifici. Això de moure l'edifici
ho he vist llegit diverses vegades, però
no m'explico com ho fan.
Però bueno, sí, és una... Seria això,
un homenatge
modern a aquest senyor
que, aparentment, pel que he llegit,
doncs, el que va escriure
va ser una de les obres túrquiques més
importants de la història antiga.
El llibre consistia en
frases curtes, com si fossin petits
consells. Aquí els tenim per les parets,
aquí traduïts al xinès,
i aquí tenim a l'uigur, i entenc
que això és uigur, però amb alfabet llatí.
He anat traduint
algunes, ells aquí suposo que han posat
les que més els ha semblat.
Mira, n'hi havia una que deia
les persones sàvies,
jo dic això d'emmemorar, eh,
més o menys, perquè traducció és una mica així.
Les persones sàvies
són les millors persones
i la saviesa és la millor
de les virtuts. Aquesta frase,
la 2015, diu,
una ment clara
i l'estat d'ordre
són els pilars de la nació.
Jutjo tots els assumptes
basats en la justícia,
tant si ets un noble com si ets
un esclau. Aquí, clar, només hi ha
les que són de bon rotllo, suposo, però n'hi havia
algunes que no eren tant de bon rotllo. Per exemple,
n'hi ha una que diu, no deixis
mai a les dones sense
vigilància. Atès
que de les dones venen
tota mena de conductes inadequades
pels homes. El tio també es queixava de la vida,
es creia nutricionista. I hi ha una de les
fases que diu, menjar massa
provoca mala digestió
i la mala digestió provoca
malaltia. I després, l'última,
la meva preferida,
diu, si casa teva neta
vols tenir, compta
amb Clean & Iron. Sí.
Fa mil anys ja ho sabien, tu.
Clean & Iron, 5% de descompte
a la seva web
sosclean.com amb el codi
Enric Luzant. Com vaig començar
el meu canal de YouTube, vaig començar
des de zero, sense ajuda de ningú
i, a poc a poc, al final
me n'he sortit. Però, clar,
quan deixes tot per emprendre
una cosa, doncs sempre hi ha aquest
perill de començar de zero
i de no saps com t'anirà. Si tu obres
una franquícia de Clean & Iron per qui vols començar
el teu propi negoci, doncs no, no comences
des de zero perquè Clean & Iron t'aporta
les eines, el coneixement, t'expliquen
com es fa, els productes
i la imatge de marca.
La publicitat tampoc l'has de fer perquè ja te la has de fer.
La faig jo. I l'experiència
de ja estar treballant des de
el 1987
Clean & Iron. Més
de 39 anys
d'experiència ja. Quan
escoltes autònoms i empresaris parlar
als mitjans de comunicacions, t'ho venen tot com que
és un desastre i és un
supercomplicat i
és un rotllo. No et diuen mai
les parts bones. Home, les parts bones és que, doncs,
pots fer els horaris que vulguis, ets el teu propi
cap, etcètera, etcètera. Si t'animes
a obrir una franquícia de Clean & Iron
ten un 5% de descompte, també, amb el mateix
descompte, amb el mateix codi de descompte,
enricluzant, contacta'ls per la seva
web o per l'Instagram
o per on sigui. Jo t'animo. Bé, i ara el que
vol saber tothom, que és el que em pregunteu cada dia,
com va el visat de Pakistan? Avui és dissabte
26, he dit.
Bueno, dissabte. No hi ha novetats.
Cap novetat. Vaig dir fa uns
dies que hi havia un home que em va
contactar que era com... tenia
influència en la política de Pakistan, alguna cosa així.
Bueno, doncs, em va dir que
ok, que s'ho miraria, però de moment, cap notícia.
Estic preocupat. Doncs...
sí. No és una cosa
que hi pensi tant, és a dir, no és que
estigui angoixat ni pugui
deixar de dormir, no? No, no és per tant,
però, clar, no ho sé.
Si la setmana que ve encara no ho tinc,
doncs, començaré a mirar
alternatives. Sí, sí, sí, sí. Ho vaig
explicar amb més profunditat al directe, el que vaig fer l'altre dia.
Aneu a donar-li una ullada.
Jo què sé, potser el
dilluns ja el tinc, no?
En qualsevol cas, o sigui, no ho sé, però
dilluns em començaré a moure d'altres maneres
que
no ho sé.
M'hauria de moure abans, tipus...
Sí, ja a trucar,
he trucat a molts llocs, però jo què sé,
parlar amb agències de viatges de Pakistan perquè em puguin...
No ho sé,
moure-ho d'una manera d'ells com que...
fent com que ells em recomanen a mi, no?
Com una carta d'invitació o alguna cosa així.
I també
començaré a mirar alternatives, que serà...
Si he d'agafar un avió des d'aquí
a l'Índia, bueno, suposo
que directe segur que no n'hi ha, no?
Però jo què sé, sí.
Sí, començaré a...
a...
a mirar-m'ho.
No sé, està complicat.
Això sortirà diumenge,
dimarts teniu l'entrevista
amb el Balenciades Sense Fronteres
i a partir d'aquí jo ja crec que...
que no en tinc
molt més a explicar de Xinjiang.
Si em moc per una altra banda, si vaig a un altre lloc,
doncs potser faig un altre vídeo, però...
no hi ha molt més xitxa a explicar.
Per tant, potser esteu uns quants dies,
una setmana sense ser, sense saber res de mi,
més enllà del que et posi a Instagram,
perquè, a veure, tampoc puc estar...
fent vídeos al bulto, no?
Ja m'enteneu.
Però, bueno, jo confio que la setmana que ve arribi, home.
Jo confio que sí.
In xalà.
Bona tarda i bona nit.